[Music]
time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week with CBS
News chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook and CBS News contributor dr. Tara
Narula we begin with two new studies out
this week examining the role of exercise
and nutrition in recovery from colon
cancer John looks at the details
five years ago Dave strong and his wife
Mary decided to get in shape they
changed their diet and hit the gym five
days a week after turning fifty last
year strong had his first colonoscopy
the first thing I saw was my wife over
me with tears in her eyes so I knew
immediately something was bad the bad
news was colon cancer that had already
spread to his liver he's had three
surgeries and is about to start his last
five treatments of chemo I push myself
when I could I slowed down when I had to
but I tried to keep the normalcy going
he continues to eat healthy and work out
new research suggests those kinds of
lifestyle choices can help one study
followed patients with colon cancer who
had completed treatment researchers
scored them based on body weight
physical activity and dietary choices
those with the highest scores had a 42%
lower chance of dying over seven years
dr. Charles Fuchs at the Yale Cancer
Center co-authored both studies the diet
probably changed your body's chemistry
in a way that makes the growth of cancer
far more hostile in another study colon
cancer patients who ate at least two
servings of tree nuts a week had a 46%
lower chance of relapse over seven years
tree nuts like almonds walnuts and
cashews helped control insulin levels
and it's believed insulin can fuel the
growth of colon cancer cells by taking
nuts you reduce your risk your diabetes
and for colon cancer patients you reduce
the likelihood of the cancer coming back
wow that's fascinating the just
fascinate is so interesting that we're
not talking about pills here we're
talking about lifestyles exercise things
like that and diet and actually these
kind of studies don't prove cause and
effect but they do make sense from a
scientific point of view the
that if you could drive down insulin
levels in the body it might make a
difference yeah I found out something I
didn't know in the lab when they're
trying to make colon cancer cells grow
they add insulin Wow Wow eat your tree
nuts yes our next topic vaccinations and
international travel most measles
infections in the u.s. are the result of
travelers returning home to this country
a study published this week in the
annals of internal medicine looked at
travelers headed overseas and how
frequently they refused vaccinations for
the measles mumps and rubella prior to
traveling the data included adults who
visit a network of clinics that focus on
international travel health over 6500
people were eligible for the vaccine at
the time of their clinic visits however
over half did not get vaccinated during
the consultation tower what were the
reasons for that 48% of it was travelers
refusing mostly because of lack of
concern 28% was provider decision saying
they don't need it usually and about 24%
were health system barriers so for
instance the clinic would send them back
to their primary care to get vaccinated
I think the biggest issue is really
educating travelers that this is a
travel related illness I don't think
that people think about measles mumps
and rubella is something that they could
get abroad but in fact measles for
example has been eliminated in this
country since 2000 but we still have
outbreaks these outbreaks if you trace
them back they are coming from an
imported source over half of these cases
that are coming back are in u.s.
travelers who were unvaccinated so very
important to get that word out important
to get these vaccinations before you go
abroad especially not only to protect
your own health but those of those in
this country who are don't have the
immunity to fight off so they are
immunosuppressed or babies for instance
who are too young to get vaccinated John
did the study drill down into that
resistance and how to convince patients
yeah well Tara mentioned most of it
about three-quarters of the people just
were not concerned about the illness is
no big deal and it's true measles can
come and go but it can also cause
serious problems like encephalitis and
even death and as Tara said even if
you're not concerned about yourself you
have to be concerned about the other
people and you said it beautifully
which is you can bring it into another
community that's just happened in
Minnesota somebody came back possibly
but somehow there was a group of people
there who were unvaccinated and they got
the measles there are people who can't
get it and again I go to the baby that
you don't get the first shot until
you're about 12 months old right so what
happens between then and birth you can
get it if somebody comes back whatever
right what are the current
recommendations Tara if you're traveling
in terms of the vaccine yeah so the CDC
has a website they do have
recommendations and that is essentially
that for teenagers or adults who do not
have immunity they should get two doses
of the vaccine separated by about 28
days so to know if you're immune or not
if you have a blood test that shows
antibodies you would be immune if you
were born before 1957 when there were
lots of measles cases you would be mewn
or if you've already had measles for
instance when it comes to infants if you
have an infant and you're going to
travel before they're one year old they
should get a shot between six and 11
months and then two more doses after the
age of one against separated by 28 days
you know this is a very infectious
disease if people are not immunized and
they're exposed over ninety percent of
them are going to get this infection and
the vaccine is very effective 97%
effective against measles about 88%
effective against mumps finally quitting
smoking can be a major challenge but a
little encouragement can go a long way a
new study by the American Cancer Society
looked at the role that emails can play
in helping people quit the study
included around a thousand smokers who
were planning to stop it found that the
group that received the most personally
tailored emails had the highest
abstinence rate followed by those who
got the second most and then those who
received only one non tailored email so
what I'm learning from this Tara is stay
in touch with your friends who are
trying to quit smoking yes you know I
think they comment about how it's that
personalized messaging that makes you
feel like somebody cares that somebody
wants you to succeed and we know that
just in general people who tend to be
married who have strong social support
systems there studies that show they
live longer they have less
cardiovascular disease so that network
of support even if it comes in the form
of an email is important I'm wondering
what the typical email is supposed to
say well well don't give up yeah I think
they'll surrender
the technical medical term for what you
need in your life is a nudge nudge works
well community helps for all kinds of
health outcomes right dr. strong LaPook
and tara Narula thanks as always